- C'est commt t t t t t t t t te
de guerre. Entouré des habitants
de Mayfield, Joe Biden est venu
constater l'ampleur des dégâts
et a
à une communauté en état
de choc.
Tout est à reconstruire ici.
"La façon dont les gens
s'entrce que nous sommes supposs
faire ici. Il n'y a pas
d'États rouges ou bleus
quand une telle chose arrive."
ont péri au Kentucky, dont
8 à l'usine de chandelles.y y yt
toujours lorsque la tornade
a frappé. Aujourd'hui,
des employés accusent
l'entreprise dchés de rentrer c.
"J'ai dit à mon superviseur :
"Vous allez refuser
de nous laisser partir même
si le temps empire?', dit-il.
partir, mais vous n'aurez
plus d'emploi.'"
Une enquête est en cours.
Pendant qu'on règledes comptese
de Mayfield, un spectacle
encore plus désolant
Ici, à Dawson Springs,
la tornade a frappé très fort.
C'est la ville la pllelelelelele
qui a été la plus affligée.
m m m m maisons ont été
détruites. On a l'impression
que cette ville a été rayée
"Il n'y a plus rien ici,
dit Thomy Shelby, et
ils ne vont pas recoLaLaLaLaLaLs
pour nous avertir que la tornade
arrivait", dit Duffy Adams, qui
s'est protégé avec son matelas.
"La d d d d d déplacé
ma maison de quatre mètres,
dit-il, et a emporté la maison
Juste à côté, un trou béant.
La maison s'est volatilisée,
retrouvé un peu plus loin.
Sur le peieieieieieieieieieieie
soigneusement l'entrée,me s'il e
résidence. La tornade a emporté
sa grand-mère avec sa maison.
"On l'appelait 'Grandma K',
gentille. On a appris sa mort
samedi, dit-elle. ppppppp
pleuré. C'était très triste."
Flora garde de précieux
tornade ne pourra emporter.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada,
Dawson Springs, Kentuck